[Music]  with the cinder I initiate you into the  world of the most sacred and pleasurable  sex my dream is to open a franchise of  the Kama Sutra garden in every town in  every city  I'm Nicole I'm Katherine Carly my name  is Michelle Sundari  [Music]  for me there is nothing wrong with  giving and getting pleasure sex is  divine always start with blessing your  partner namaste my name is Terra  when I was 13 years old my mother got a  job at a brothel like this make sure  that you're happy with your choice right  you could come inside  [Music]  rejects me Lucia I'd love to meet her  she really exists sometimes when I see a  falling star I close my eyes and make a  wish  don't be a favor  [Music]  and promise you memories that will last  a lifetime  [Music]